[Music]
I'm standing at my position glancing
around at my teammates around me heart
is pounding my muscles are tense I'm
ready to sprint the whistle blows and
the ball is in the air my first
international rugby game luxembourg
against germany started we tackle we
follow we cut it back up and we all gave
our best so in the end we celebrated
ourselves together with the german team
why am I telling the story team sport is
about a lot more than just exercising
together with others team sports have
great benefits for individuals for
companies and for communities so what's
in it for you as an individual we all
know that regular exercise has physical
and mental benefits so I don't need to
go into detail for that but I just
wanted to say it anyway but did you know
that 3 out of 4 corporate executives
play team sport look at the CEOs of HP
GE Bank of America I'm not saying you
that team sports will guarantee you a
higher salary and a better position but
I can tell you that there's a great
correlation between leadership qualities
and having played on a team as I learned
from former dean Bob Joss great
leadership is easy to recognize but hard
to practice team sports give you a
platform to practice these leadership
skills where else would you learn how to
make decisions under pressure inspire
others around you learn to deal with
failures and take our responsibility and
most of the time you're having fun
because you're not noticing you're
learning so team sports health leaders
to hone the leadership capabilities but
they also have benefits for companies as
a whole let's have a look at my job as
management consultant I was sitting at
the laptop all day and all night
very far away from team sports that's
what you think but then our annual
European soccer and volleyball
tournament came up we organized
ourselves and practice regularly we
didn't only get better as a team on the
tournament we formed bonds with each
other that go way beyond this tournament
today studies have shown that corporate
leagues instead of camaraderie amongst
employees they improve the work
environment and ultimately lead to
better company performance active
employees require lower health premium
and have less sick days corporate
leagues make networking easy especially
amongst hierarchy levels make a good
position on the softball team and then
you might be invited for the next
corporate initiative and I can assure
you you'll have something to talk about
at the next awkward company networking
event
Sarris corporately increased the bonds
between employees city leagues have
communities grow closer together it has
been shown that people who move to new
countries will find a lot easier to
integrate when they join the local
sports team religion race background
become irrelevant language barriers are
overcome because the team sport is the
common language many refugees are
looking for shelter in Germany so do
they in my hometown Essen the local
soccer teams in assam as does my brother
soccer team as well have opened their
doors for refugees to participate in the
practice so that the refugees can meet
the locals and both groups benefit the
refugees get to know a new culture and
they learn a new language the club
members get to experience
multiculturalism without having to buy
an expensive plane ticket to go
somewhere else but we don't need to go
overseas to experience how team sport
shapes the community let me invite you
to trip across the 101 to the East Palo
Alto Razorbacks a local rugby team
former Stanford coat rub holder has
given the young man from the former
murder capital of the US a reason to
believe in themselves
he's given them the perspective and a
motivation to stay out of trouble and
he's given them the opportunity to win
the Division two national championship
most impressive is a story of Fulani a
high school dropout who's already some
jail time in his youth being part of
that team changed his life now he's a
permanent tire in the USA sevens rugby
national team the Eagles and just last
weekend he played in Vegas for the big
rugby tournament but now the big
question that I think asking myself why
aren't more people playing team sports a
recent Harvard study has shown that
after college there's a very sharp drop
out despite all these benefits three out
of four adults played when they were
younger but only one out of four still
play today
I asked more than a hundred of you and
the statistics are exactly the same we
here at the GSB are not any better than
the nation's average I like to
acknowledge that people find it
challenging and myself included to play
team sports you might say I don't have
the time you might say it's not flexible
enough for me you might wonder am I good
enough to join a team you might say I'm
worried about my health and you might
wonder Hannah where and how can I join a
team think about it you're putting in so
much money and time for your
professional leadership education what
if you could get a good chunk of it just
by joining a team so what can you do as
a future leader what can you do for
yourself as an individual what can you
do for your company or can you do for
your community I've got three
recommendations first
to enter a recreational league team it's
never too late to get back into the game
or you can try something new Silicon
Valley hasn't stopped here there's apps
for that too
so there's apps to find other players
and to organize pickup games but also
traditional methods as your local
community newspaper a visit at the YMCA
or talking to your friends to
word-of-mouth will work second
start a corporate League team in your
company
this will help connect employees and
create a more harmonious work
environment ultimately leading to better
performance and guess what you aren't
shredded very early on third look for
initiatives in your community that you
can support like the new grass field for
the kids to play on to stay out of
trouble or support the local soccer club
to give them new jerseys and equipment
coming back to my international game we
slot really hard we check held we fell
to the ground we got bigger we sprint it
we ran after the others we gave our best
I get well in the end we lost and we
didn't we didn't just lose we got
crushed
you got hammered 100 to 0
but for us it was not about winning it
was about being part of a team it was
about persevering to the very end it was
about being united for a common goal I
believe in the power of team sports to
enrich each individual's life I believe
in the power of team sports to create
high-performing organization I believe
in the power of team sports to make the
world a better place now if your turn to
get back into the game
[Applause]
[Music]